- [Instructor] Having
become the first person
to complete the 1500-meter
freestyle swim at age 100,
a smile was worn by Mieko Nagaoka.
So the way it's written right now,
it makes it seem like a smile, a smile,
was the first person to complete
the 1500-meter freestyle
swim at age 100, which
doesn't make much sense.
And let's just think
about what's going on here
when you read this,
when someone is reading,
when someone's reading, I'll
do this in a different color,
when someone is reading this part,
that I'll underline in red,
having become the first person
to complete the 1500-meter
freestyle swim at age 100,
and then there's the comma,
your brain is expecting that
the first thing you read
is what was being described,
the first person to complete
the 1500-meter freestyle swim.
But then you see a smile, so
it looks like they're talking
about the smile was the
first person to complete
the 1500-meter freestyle
swim, but we of course know
that we're not talking about a smile,
we're talking about Mieko Nagaoka.
So this second part right over here,
I want it to start with
Mieko, Mieko Nagaoka,
was wearing a smile, maybe.
So I definitely wanna change it.
I definitely, definitely wanna change it.
So let's see, having
become the first person
to do all this stuff,
happiness was evident.
Well no, now it seems like
happiness was the first person
to complete the 1500-meter freestyle swim.
So I don't like that choice.
Having become the first
person to do all this stuff,
Mieko Nagaoka wore a smile,
yep, that feels good,
'cause the first thing you see,
that was what was intended
to be the first person
to complete the 1500-meter
freestyle swim at age 100,
so I'm liking this one.
And this last choice,
it still has a smile,
it's written, it makes
it seem like a smile
was the first person to
complete the 1500-meter
freestyle swim so I don't
like this one either
so I feel very good about this choice.